do you guys think women lack femininity
today and is that something you look for
when you're looking for a partner
tag you're it
i want to i want to hit you upside down
there you
go do women lack femininity um
i'm going to say blankly i'm not going
to say a blanket yes but i do think a
lot of women have
forgotten how to use their sexual wilds
to get things from men your grandparents
and probably your parents would have
known to do things as well that's one
thing
and wait can you repeat that sorry i
think i said i'm not going to use a
blanket statement and say all women have
lost your femininity that's quite the
case but i think a lot of you have a lot
of you chasing his whole boss babe thing
and
that aggressive sort of nature that
comes with being a boss bae don't really
work for men that's one thing and i also
think a lot of you lost how to
the subtle art
of using your sexual wilds to get what
you want from sexual aware agreed
have you have you not seen girls on only
fans no that's one
[Music]
world
wild
so being being obviously six uh your
sexuality yeah so being all defined is
different to getting
there are ways
only fans you're not exactly
getting to
have sex with women
and the only fans you're not exactly
getting to have sex with a woman you're
just they're you're paying to watch them
present themselves on that so there are
ways that would make us speak to men to
get things that are men
that
you should can i have an example should
we do that is
first of all
so for example
you can say to me hey d can you put the
bins out you say to me baby the bins are
a bit rough can you take them up oh i
understand what you're saying yeah you
know he's the thing he's those are yeah
that's usually permanent femininity when
you say that you don't just be like yeah
you know okay
and a lot of women have forgotten to do
that especially nowadays a lot of you
forgot no you know those
feminism went because
there was like a time where feminism was
like okay a woman has to be like a man
to be respected and women really kind of
like started owning that and becoming a
lot more like men stopped dressing
feminine started wearing suits to be
respected like men i think that's
probably where that mindset probably
comes from is like lose the femininity
become more masculine and get respected
so i think that's where that lies i
think it's like woman trying to find
equality in that going down this route
but like now we know like maybe it's
probably not the right route i agree
with that but so in a bit in the
business world in the work world that
may work for you but it doesn't work for
your leadership world because if i
wanted to when someone was act like a
man why'd i not just get a man
yeah
if you're looking from a perspective of
like
a woman has to like back in the day the
woman knew her like you know oh
the way we do for somebody like you the
way you're talking and stuff like that
it's like oh baby or the honey whatever
like you know you used that type of like
you were sitting at home
now now nowadays from what i've seen it
was it was more like a table hey yo like
some some girls like um tomboys right
two like breasts
like for real like happy like for
example sometimes i'll be speaking to
you like i've seen i've seen uh i know
one of my friends um i'm kind of megan
right i'd say i'm a tomboy are you
telling me
i just tend to enjoy things that guys
like and i'm not really into like makeup
but i still think you used to have a
feminine element like i still found you
but if the right guy if the right guy
walked by right
back
you'd be making music
i think you can do a lot with the eyes i
think hair playing is a bit you know
yeah but i think you're kind of flirty
with everyone i feel like i'm just being
nice i mean i think it's just my it's
just how i am yeah i know i know it's
like feminine though oh okay
that's why that's what i'm gonna call
you masculine yeah i think it's just
weird because like for like since i was
little i was always like the tomboy like
you know i had an older brother i'd
literally like
this fight with them yeah
every woman at certain stages went
through that tomboy stage though
no as i said i feel like i feel like at
a certain point it might have been a
long term but i feel like every girl at
some point has got has been or will go
through like a tomboy stage-ish i think
it's just like pre-progressing because
like everyone like proof person isn't
really like doesn't really go into their
gender that like i feel like the gender
roles or the gender types aren't that
distinct i think femininity in
masculinity isn't that strong in like
kindergarten or like in like middle
school like when children are quite
young you don't really like okay he's
he's acting very masculine or acting
very feminine then that comes when you
grow and mature so
ladies so is it is is femininity a bad
thing i think feminist is great i feel
like a woman should embrace her
femininity and i feel like it's a shame
that we went through that phase that
women had to try and be like men to be
respected i feel like it's a shame that
we had to
like hide a femininity to have that kind
of respect because it is true like a
very feminine woman isn't respected the
same way
like just in the workplace in general
like in a professional world like a
woman's very feminine like oh she's a
blonde she's not very smart i don't i
haven't had like i've found that girls
that are feminine in the workplace get
more favors from men
but that's at the cost of i don't think
this woman is intelligent enough to do
that by herself it's like i'm going to
help her and flirt with no not really
like because i just was and the only
girl in an office of like 25 people and
when i was working there the guys that
were kind of on the same like job as me
they would always tell me
that um i only got help with certain
things because i was a girl and at first
i kind of was like yeah whatever but in
hindsight like
kind of because all the managers would
like help me with whatever i wanted like
drop everything
do special like one-on-one time they
would ask for the same thing it'd be
like weeks
i'd get it yeah can i ask you girls a
question right
would you respect a man that's like
feminine and as an open open about like
his feelings like he's not he's not
afraid to black ops about your feelings
he's not feminine no but i'm saying like
he's like he's sorry okay
would you would you be like do you
respect a man that's like open about
like his feelings and like he's like not
ashamed to like cry in front of you and
supply and stuff like that would you
like no no
no exactly yes that's the way that
stuff's awesome i'm sorry i like it okay
open like oh no not not a degree where
it's like like you nikki knock where
he's capable but like in front of you
like he's he's open about his feelings
he's like you know he's not afraid to
cry something you know
i've been in a situation like that it
was just exhausting so i was like you
have so many feelings
but when you girls give us stuff and we
just have to sit there and we'll be like
i support you darling like you know
i think a lot of people that i mean like
i would say like you're pretty like i'd
say in touch with your emotions but
you're not like
very emotional like you know you're not
like crying all over yeah you know i
would say like i'm all public that way
like i'm not i'm very i keep everything
inside and so like if i were to have to
deal with someone that's very open about
it i feel like that would be a lot for
me to deal with too i think it just
depends on how that person
also expresses their i think i think
there's a difference between being
emotionally unavailable like to a toxic
like extent like the point like okay
like this person's given really mixed
signals this person doesn't know how to
act like a human being
then to being okay like i don't want to
express my emotions all the time like
sometimes i don't need to cry right now
sometimes but it's not a big deal
sometimes you can you know like work
through things it's not always about
expressing emotions in like big bits of
rage or being like too angry or those
kind of things i think it's about
balance like having the bare minimum is
expressing your emotions i'm happy i'm
sad i like this i enjoy this like being
direct i think there's a difference
between completely hiding your emotions
so that the woman's like are you
actually okay so something wrong like
always to keep guessing i don't think
that's a positive but
what would you say would that be like um
like a red flag for some girls i think
it's a red flag if a man can't openly
talk about um what he's feeling i'm
saying to a girl like if a man's
actually like
is not afraid to express his feelings
you know you're all emotional and stuff
like do you think some girls that would
be like a red flag i mean i think for
some people maybe but i feel like for me
no i think it'd be quite refreshing to
have a guy express his emotions if he's
happy like i'm happy like it doesn't
have to be always about something sad it
can be like oh like i really appreciate
what you did today or i really support
you or like oh i got frustrated when you
did that can we talk about this can we
talk about about that like it doesn't
always have to be like oh a guy cried
because his mom died like it's not just
that because it's gonna happen probably
like what once well yes right i wouldn't
categorize like emotional ass
[Laughter]
i wouldn't categorize like being
emotional as like a red flag maybe it's
just like to
not i wouldn't say like overly emotional
but like you know maybe it's just not a
turn on or it might be a turn off for
the girl it's just windows not used to
it i think that's probably why it
depends on like personal preference i
just think it's how often like that like
how often is he
like like like three days out of the
five like three times
okay
like like once once a month once
i think we're going into like
personality types here yeah i feel like
there's being emotional then just having
that personality type that's kind of
like you're affected by everything like
a bit like kind of like a snowflake that
everything's like the world's against
you like like this isn't like i respect
my dad a lot right and he's like not an
emotional guy and he's always really in
control of his emotions and i've seen my
dad cry but like i can only count
like maybe twice in my life yeah and you
maybe seen him cry yeah of course
and
of course like i would respect that more
than like
once a month i'm like sorry i think
maybe it's like without crying kind of
like you respect the guys that are tough
like you you like
looking up to guys that like can handle
their emotions and just are tough
yeah yeah you like that you you like
those type of guys they're like no
matter how what type of pain they're
going through they'll be like i'm fine
yeah and it's a scene like your house
just burnt down and the guy's like it's
calm it's fine no no no no no no no no
they're like our children are dead in
the house oh
but that doesn't happen once a month
that's like a once in a lifetime
way it happened yeah like like i think
this is the same chances that someone
actually has to cry
[Laughter]
um
don't come for me
let's park the extreme examples away the
extreme examples of a husband and
children dying yeah yeah that's nature
that's that's not that's unliked up to
most people's lives let's say like your
mom dies let's park extremely things
let's let's talk about day to day so the
problem the issue with
guys being emotional is this
we don't know what your level of
tolerance is what your level of
tolerance is or your level of provinces
so we don't know from who we meet what
you may think is acceptable emotions or
not right
now
okay
so therefore
it's just a safe bet
to show as little as possible because
what you may think is too much you may
think it's not enough
so let's keep it
give it level of stoic second point to
that is this
if you're quite emotional person if
you're going through emotions we both
can't be going for emotions whenever
it's gotta be level headed and see the
right the the wood for the trees
some of us one of us have got to be able
to see okay you're going for some [ __ ]
one of us could be like you know what
the logical voice right so we're both
going for our feelings
we're worth going for our feelings all
the [ __ ] time especially the same
points
nothing's ever gonna be accomplished
because you're both gonna be worried
about what's now and not seeing the
bigger picture of things and seeing
what's
really important one of us has to be
that person that can say that this is an
issue
we can work through this that's why this
is where we work through this space how
we get so we power through this this
scenario so we power through this
relationship issue this very powerful
power for this money issue whatever it
is
one of us has to be able to say let's
just work through i think that's a
really strong point what you're saying
there but i also do think when you're
going for a relationship like you have
the same problems it's good that someone
can be the strong voice of reason and
say okay we're going to do this
but i also think like if you go through
like a serious problem let's say
financial difficulty and the person
doesn't acknowledge the emotions that
are at play in that situation i do think
it'd lead to like the relationship
breaking up all together even if the
voice of reason makes sense and is
logical i do think it may cause the
relationship become distant because
someone is not acknowledging the real
effects of what's happening so i feel
like emotions should also be intertwined
within the voice of reason but like you
have to acknowledge them i think that's
what we mean by being emotional we're
not asking for men to cry we're just
asking to men like okay this has
affected me i'm upset
i'm happy like just you know be vocal
about what's going on before you're
meant to say right it's a problem we're
going through this is the plan and we
get through it rather than sitting and
dwelling in the problem and saying oh
you don't have to [ __ ] has happened both
get upset about it i'm going to we've
got a problem with the relationship it's
not me
it's not mutually exclusive to be
logical and also feel at the same time i
do think you can have emotions and make
a decision so okay my car's crashed i'm
so annoyed but let's go to let's go to
the insurance call them up like
one doesn't mean the other one can't
happen
i'm sorry i'm sorry but any any person
that calls uk's insurance you're done
out here yeah like if it's like no no no
you and anyone that drives a car will
agree with me right in the uk if you
crash a car
i'm sorry it's like this is you don't
have a gasoline insurance company you're
i'm sorry you are done out i think like
you just need to be able to acknowledge
him i'm not asking the guy to cry just
like acknowledge okay yeah this is
upsetting this is good it's bad like if
someone's just not acknowledging it's
like what does that do for me
like for me it shows me that this
person's also feeling what i'm feeling
it just doesn't mean that i'm like okay
i'm living with someone at this point
i think it's so even today and this
isn't like because i look up to my dad a
lot right yeah i like called him i was
freaking out because um you guys you
don't even know what happened to me
today
i i want you to do this i went through
hell and back to get you guys this sound
board tonight
and basically
the guy off of facebook didn't give me
the power cord so i went to go get it
today because he forgot and
yeah i left my id
and my my wallet and my keys on the on
the train and i i know yes i said super
chats please
wait
no and so no so it was really cool
because i didn't even know if i could do
the show tonight
oh no don't do it
i didn't i didn't i didn't even know if
i could do the show tonight cause i was
locked out of my apartment and and my
the company was like
you know my the company was um closed
for the weekend because it's easter
yeah and i and i had my phone dead it
was a lot but anyways i i ended up
getting my phone charged and calling my
mom and my dad and my mom's reaction was
like
like you should have had a spare key and
my dad's reaction was like okay you're
you're alive you haven't like lost the
limb it's okay and i was like i look i
cried i'm gonna lie to you
emotionally no oh my god okay
oh my god this was such a bad day
and um yeah and i was just like that
like stoic i just i i admire that men
when they're like calm stoic they don't
get emotional that like because my mom
is like pissed because i'm like you have
to cancel like the credit cards you have
to do that and my like my mom was like
freaking out this is why this is why i
like dealing with dad like you know i do
i do see what you mean that i do think
like having a voice of reason is
important but also like okay let's say
you're not having a problem let's say
it's like an event that's a positive
event let's say you get married and your
dad's completely stoic the whole time
let's say you give birth and you have a
child in your dad's right whatever just
another monday right let's go to work i
don't give too like he doesn't care
like someone to be happy for you i just
want someone to have the balance of both
positive and negative emotions so i i
love that i can call my dad and he can
give me like a voice of reason all that
stuff do this this and this but like i
wish there was a balance in between the
emotions of my mother and the the but
isn't it
wouldn't it be more valuable if your dad
is stoic all the time and he cried at
your wedding
like do you know what i mean versus
that's good emotion though
that's that's like that's what i mean
like like it means more if like if he's
tough most of the time and strong and
then occasionally you have that like
glimmer of emotion like don't think
that's true but then like what does that
say about your dad like did he just say
like he oh yeah he bottles up all his
emotions
he controls them yeah but like like
because we like a guy in control
i guess but i think he can be in control
and also experience emotions and express
your emotions like one of the times i
saw my dad cry okay this this literally
convinced me i i smoked weed once in
high school of course you did yeah no i
really i didn't even like it but my dad
was so mad at me he like like he cried i
swear to god and i
i'm what you know yeah because my
because you know like
that generation
like you know it's this is yes it was
funny they thought i was a stoner and i
swear to god
and i started out
it was one it was one time i started it
was like the only time i ever
i ever smoked and i literally it was
like the friends were big stoners and i
was like coughing the whole time i hated
it it was so stupid
and like my dad cried and it just like
it made me listen yeah libby listened to
him because he was so mad
yeah i think you're right i think it's
more it's more profound when someone
doesn't express that emotion often so if
someone like let's say your mother never
shouts to you like never and then your
mother shouts to you one time then i'm
like whoa like mom like did i do
something makes you listen it makes you
listen yeah if you think if you don't do
something often people react to it
but then at the same time like do you
want someone only to show emotion at
like one day in your whole life if you
get married once and it's gonna be one
time your father will cry i mean i
prefer it yeah i mean like that versus
once a month
i don't know i don't know you have no
soul
have you ever been of a guy who
expresses emotions that frequently
i don't think i've ever been with a guy
that's expressed his emotions so i can't
even compare accurately so this is just
me playing devil's advocate here like i
haven't actually been with a guy that's
so been so expressive of his emotions do
you think you think you recently haven't
been fundamentally not attracted to it
i don't think you when you're dating
someone i don't think men will show that
side to them so regardless of that guy
is emotional in the future you wouldn't
know from the first day anyway so you'd
have to date this person for quite a
long time to open that kind of
have you ever had long term relationship
with someone yeah i've been in a lot of
long-term relationships maybe two
long-term relationships over the years
so in those periods times those guys
show emotions in the way you describe
right now yes and you found attractive
at a time
it's not about fun and attractive it's
about like this person being quite open
with you if you're like in a partnership
with someone long term and they're
comfortable to show their emotions i
think it's very telling of the kind of
relationship that you have but it does
show
it's something that could be a turn off
no i don't think it could be a turn off
no so if someone's going through
something really hard because they're
going through something really difficult
it's not turn off
but also i don't think when she's saying
like showing emotion emotion i don't
think she means like oh like the man's
just like crying i think that's just him
like telling him oh like i really enjoy
doing this with you it made me really
happy like not just negative emotions
it's not always about crying it's also
about happiness just like
acknowledgement of what you guys like
like maybe like did together like oh i
really enjoyed this together like
enjoyment happiness or like it doesn't
always have to be frustrational doesn't
mean like extremes you know it can just
be like a subtle yeah this guy's not
going to be mourning once a month this
is going to be like oh i'm happy that
you did this today i'm really proud of
you or like oh this frustrated me
imagine if a guy doesn't tell you he's
frustrated with something like he's just
going to hold on to that and you won't
know and then that's going to lead to
problems in the relationship
i mean i think it's one thing if a guy
was like oh you hurt my feelings or
versus a guy saying okay you did that
and i won't tolerate it
one one is one is more attractive and
you know which one it is
like you you know
oh you hurt me and i won't tolerate it
and you know maybe like i didn't mean to
do it and i feel like that kind of would
just kind of like hurt my heart
and then like
of course like
i can open
and like i feel like like you know that
would be like the kind of turn off for
me because like you know maybe i
like obviously i hurt you but it's not
like i purposely did it to hurt you yeah
but then for you just be like oh i don't
tolerate it right but i'm sorry i'm
sorry i'm gonna disagree with you a
little bit on that one because i've said
this absolutely since you were talking
while i was talking oh wow
no what i was going to say was like look
no ma i know my heart sometimes tells
you what you said i agree with you
completely because like
girls as much as funny sanjay they just
like if you
like did something wrong and a guy is
like it's one thing to do something
wrong and a guy just looks positive but
when a guy is like hey like you know
most girls it's funny they'd like to
hear that sit down and shut the [ __ ] up
[ __ ] you know what i mean like and that
[ __ ] is a turnover them
might not be you might not be you but
for some girls would they like that
sturdy when it's kind of like you're go
you're climbing on the man's like you
know you're building up the [ __ ] [ __ ]
and the man just breaks and it's a
lizard you need to yeah and then that
[ __ ] for most girls just to turn on i'm
sorry i'm not um
i'm not gonna disagree there but i think
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]